ladies and gentlemen thank you for
joining us and welcome to the second
annual forum sponsored by Hillsdale
College and talkers magazine and I want
to thank all the folks at Hillsdale
College for helping make this possible
and welcome you for coming out in the
middle of a busy day when there are so
many things in Washington DC that take
up people's time and attention let alone
your jobs to join us for this
opportunity to talk about some of the
hottest issues of our time my name is
Michael Harrison it's my privilege to
moderate this panel and it's it's being
described as a discussion and a debate I
hope it's more on the side of discussion
than debate especially considering how
volatile some of the topics we'll be
discussing have proven to be during this
chaotic period of history the title of
the panel is media and journalism in the
age of Trump and here we are a little
more than one year past the last time we
gathered some of the members of this
panel were there there are some new ones
joining us this time it was the issues
attendant to the election of 2016 we
still did not know who the winner would
be and it was a spirited discussion to
say the least now that we are almost one
year into the age of Trump each of the
people on this panel being in one way or
another a radio and or media talk show
hosts there are lots of opinions about
the effect of Donald Trump's presidency
upon journalism and the media my
perspective politically is First
Amendment that's as far as I go I do
everything I possibly can not to express
a partisan or consistent ideological
position other than my zealous support
of the First Amendment and the
Constitution of the United States
I have to grapple with what I consider
to be legitimate opinions because my as
a human being especially lately but I've
experienced this throughout my 50-year
career in this business even the most
Hardy supporters of the first amendment
to find themselves sometimes facing
crises in terms of who they're going to
support and what they will support under
certain conditions so I sort of defined
for myself the word legitimate opinions
and I realized that that's somewhat of a
cop-out but it's the best I can do and I
try to be sincere in adhering to that
everybody on this panel has a legitimate
opinion as that they express on a daily
basis in their writings on video and on
the radio airwaves both on air and
online and no longer in 2017 and you
make the assumption that somebody is a
liberal or a conservative and then
presume what that means and you can't
even presume what it means let alone on
a long consistent level in terms of the
timeline you can't presume what it means
hour to hour the news cycle is so fast
these days
that most people in the news business
are on overload it's like going warped
in on a starship that only goes warp 9
and at best will fall apart I've got it
going as fast as I can no more news more
stories when I occasionally fill in on
the radio as a talk-show host I try to
do at least five or six stories at the
same time as opposed to doing many one
because by the time you're finished with
a show the one story is started might
now be obsolete that's also played havoc
with our heads in terms of time as we
all get older time seems to go quicker
today whether you're old or young time
is very difficult to get your wrap your
brain around a story that breaks on a
Monday by Wednesday or Thursday or
Friday it feels like it happened a month
ago and this is also something that
makes it very difficult
for journalists who are committed to
seeking truth as opposed to victory
because the pertinence of your story
plays such a role in the
commercialization and the corporate
strategies of today's media so I will
introduce the panel but I will leave you
with one thought perhaps we should make
it our motto if we really are sincere
about being good media people and true
journalists that we shouldn't succumb to
the present tendency in our culture
certainly beyond journalism to seek
victory at the expense of truth but to
seek truth at the expense if necessary a
victory our panel consists and I'll just
going to introduce everybody very
quickly Dom Giordano is to my immediate
left he hosts mid mornings in
Philadelphia at WP HT major radio
station and a major radio personality
his background is in education and he
has established himself as one of the
leading talk-show hosts in America next
to him is Joe Madison consistently in
the talkers magazine heavy hundred top
ten he is called by his listeners and
his constituents the black eagle i know
joe for over 25 years used to work with
him on the same station at wwr sea in
washington and i'm in awe of his career
and his role not just as a radio
performer but a civil rights and social
activist
he's with sirius XM satellite radio
heard in the morning to his left is
Janet Parshall who is the preeminent
talk show host in America for more than
a quarter of a century
representing the Christian the secular
Christian political news talk point of
view and she does that daily on the
moody radio network next to next to
Janet is John Frederick's John
Frederick's is an entrepreneur he began
his own network in Virginia and now
covers major stations across the state
of Virginia with his show on what is
called the John Frederick's radio
network he was the chairman its chairman
the word the chairman of the Trump
campaign in Virginia he was one of the
first major media figures to say Trump
would win and he I would say is probably
the most vocal ardent supporter of the
President of the United States Donald
Trump and expresses that every day so he
will play an important role in this
discussion to his left is a man who left
day to day talk radio where he was a big
star in the Midwest in the Chicago area
for a number of years in the mornings
and went to academia he is the general
manager of the radio station and the
radio program at Hillsdale College and
can provide us with very good insights
to the younger generation and the future
of broadcasting and that Scott Bertram
next to Scott Bertram we have gentlemen
who's no stranger to anybody who follows
the press and follows the media and
follows politics he's read by thousands
of people across the country for his
weekly column provided by I believe
Tribune news content and he is a pioneer
in online broadcasting a liberal who did
not succumb to being pushed out of
terrestrial radio by the tendency for
them to go for conservative news talkers
and he is heard on the TYT radio network
has a huge following every day for his
show is bill press and to the left of
bill press is a gentleman who was on
last year's panel a man I've gotten to
know over the years who I respect
tremendously as a journalist and as a
talk-show host as a lawyer
and as a as a scholar the Trump era has
been good to him and challenging to him
I'm sure played a major role during the
primaries in terms of media and
continues to be a voice of a tremendous
amount of intelligence and reason and
that is Hugh Hewitt so let's welcome our
panelists fake news think about that
there's a term that has changed over the
years
Hugh what happens when I say the word
fake news what goes on in your mind just
that the sound of those words thank you
Michael and thanks to Hillsdale for
having us Hillsdale receives no federal
funding so each get one glass of water
you know that you forgot to mention one
Michael one thing the hashtag is Hewitt
is funnier than press or I did that's
what we just want you to put out there
and you're both funnier than Dennis
Prager Prager that's the second hashtag
and they're both funnier than Prager the
fake news brings to mind a Bulgarian
young man who was interviewed during the
2016 cycle
who knows he is producing fake content
100% of the time and does it to make
money and so he sits in Bulgaria and he
produces inflammatory false news about
those parties in the United States and
he pushes it out under pseudo persuasive
banner headlines international almost
Tribune something or other and if you
know column form and it looks like news
and people fall for it all the time
because on Twitter unless you check you
can be tricked and he makes a lot of
money so for me the definition is any
sort of media put out on any platform
that is known to the purveyor to be
false
that's fake news there's a lot of it
it's a vicar very great danger in 2004 I
wrote a piece for the Weekly Standard
called black blog ops which suggested it
was only a matter of time till Karla
who's the famed agent in the lekar a
novel
would begin to use online means to
influence the election and it has come
to pass in the last two years this
ubiquitous now John Frederick's you
heard what Hugh Hewitt has just said and
during the past year I have watched and
I think we have all watched the
evolution of the term fake news to
become a favorite term of the President
of the United States some say he's
co-opted the term and now it means
anything that is put out by the
mainstream media that he doesn't agree
with how do you respond to that
perception well thanks for having me
Michael and thanks for Hillsdale College
and everyone being here let me define
the fake news the majority of the
editorial and other news coverage in the
New York Times Washington Post MSNBC CNN
Los Angeles Times I could take up the
whole panel time for doing this if you
look at CNN or MSNBC which both Joe and
Phil and I are on and you all the time
you turn CNN on today for the for the
preceding 24 hours straight
all you're going to get on CNN is
basically Trump's sucks that's their
panel that's all they do
if it rains out Trump caused the rain so
maybe they have they have certain things
that they're reporting on but they don't
talk about any of the positive things
about the economy or any of the
accomplishments that the administration
has all they want to focus on is why
Trump is bad why he's going to be
impeached obstruction of justice Michael
Flynn flipped etc and so that is the
definition of fake news you're not
turning anything on anymore and getting
an honest assessment of what is actually
going on in the in the United States and
what we found and what those in the
Trump administration have to do
every day is that the legacy media has
one objective and that is to bring this
administration down in any means or way
possible that is my definition of today
thank you John bill press what's your
reaction to what John just said thank
you Michael thank you all for being here
what a surprise
I disagree actually my definition of
fake news is anything Donald Trump says
or anything you see on Fox and Friends
I find out in my radio studio in the
morning we have three monitors with the
morning shows on the sound is down by
the way a little tip the best way to
watch television is with the sound down
I think you know what they're talking
about because you can read the captions
you just don't have to hear the [ __ ]
that either side is saying but I'm
always stunned in the morning to see Fox
and Friends and CNN and MSNBC and the
difference in what they're covering and
there could be some major breaking news
event maybe Michael Flynn might be
indicted and please guilty and you will
see that on CNN you'll see that on MSNBC
and Fox and Friends is probably talking
about the Christmas decorations at the
White House and how beautiful a
beautiful job Melania did I'm not saying
she didn't do a beautiful job I'm saying
maybe that's not the biggest story of
the day but I think that he was right
there is let's get away from the White
House for just a second there is so much
fake news going around particularly
online I think that's a danger to all of
us in our profession because a lot of
people see that they believe it they
don't have the filters to know what's
real and what's not and that's all
they're that's all they get but I think
it certainly amplified when the
President of the United States has and I
didn't think this was going to be a
partisan debate but if John's would have
started it off but I think it's
amplified when the president of the
United States has zero regard for the
truth
one little example he came out in front
of the media of yesterday on his way
into marine one and said I feel sorry
for Michael Flynn he lied to the FBI and
he got caught he's going to pay the
punishment or whatever Hillary Clinton
lied to the FBI many times and she
walked free
his zero evidence of that and I'm now
here is a Hillary defender on the Bernie
guy but zero evidence she ever lied to
the FBI and James Comey in fact the
director of the FBI testified under oath
in Congress at the end of the email
investigation where he criticized her
for having their private email server
said I find absolutely zero basis to say
that she lied to the FBI all right bill
I'm gonna jump in at this point that's
nice it might smite suffice it to say
what you're saying is that one of the
sources of fake news is the news that
comes out of the White House now I'm
going to go to you
Dom Giordano you're a host on a station
that is basically positioned
I don't know how overtly but it's
positioned and that goes back to what I
said before about today's media targets
audiences based upon identity and
political persuasion your station is
positioned as a conservative station
most of the personalities are
conservative how do you deal because I
know you're an educator and I know that
you are in your heart a very objective
truthful man how do you deal with
balancing the objectives of playing to
what's called in radio the p1 audience
and your own observation of what is
obviously a situation has pointed out by
Bill press by John good stuff comes out
and bad stuff comes out just as it has
been with every president's ear every
doggcatcher elected in this world how do
you deal with a time when the
positioning of the medium that you're
working for is don't play Led Zeppelin
on a Peter Paul and Mary station
goodness steal that line right there
well first thanks to Hillsdale for
having me I broadcast my show and their
state-of-the-art radio studio Michael
told me that everything was that and it
also had a shower in a bathroom three
feet away from me first time to talk
radio
so you guys have to come here if you're
in media and do something Revere it's
fascinating so in answer to your
question and you kind of gave us a
little tease of it a while ago for
conservatives particularly during the
election particularly in the early
stages with Trump there was all-out
warfare I speak of myself and I think I
am a conservative and I've been on with
a lot of these guys they may think that
and there were any number of things
where I thought finally the true Trump
people early on are going to sour on
this guy and some of them were in Iowa
some of them were later on that you just
can't say the sorts of things about
McCain etc so there was as I said a
pitch battle between conservatives not
never Trump errs per se and the true
Trump people early on now at this point
Michael an answer to your question a lot
of it is whatever Trump does branding
fake news or other faux pas or the
problem I have with the president is
stylistic but I think it gets into what
I like in a politician it's mangled I
like people that are opinionated can't
even be controversial but are buttoned
up in the fact pattern that we're
debating versus all over the place so
what I see though is an overreaction by
the media and that's where the defensive
Trump often comes in Brian Ross is the
latest villain in this and the view gang
sorry for that to view women that we're
celebrating prematurely about Flynn when
the facts don't take us there so what I
would say is I can speak for the other
two hosts but mostly myself this is on a
point-by-point with Trump and often what
we're going after is the overreaction in
other words going after him and savaging
him even on things that are obvious and
being patient with it but there's an
impatience here where people were
throwing around drugs and dementia and
they don't like milania's christmas
decorations I think it's kind of a
mistake to be going after Melania Trump
of all people here and that's where the
tension comes in every day and that's
why I don't feel talk radio is in this
statement where you know
what the talking points going to be Fox
and Friends I get the criticism but talk
radio in general with a couple of
national exceptions you're seeing people
wrestle with this and I'll admit it is
hard in that atmosphere to be too
critical of Trump but there is criticism
provoked by how over-the-top the
opposition is thank you
Janet Parshall let's approach this topic
and you can react to everything that
you've heard adding to it
what is the Christian and secular news
talk perspective on this topic hugely
important question first of all thank
you very much and thanks to Hillsdale
College and you have to have sympathy
for this man put a bunch of stalkers on
a panel it's like herding cats so thank
you for the way you're handling this
thank you when you you started out with
the question that was very important you
said when you hear the words fake news
what goes through your mind and I'm
looking at this from a colloquial
perspective the populist perspective
because if we're really going to be
effective in our line of work while
we're called talkers in order to be
really good we have to be listeners so
what do our listeners saying back to us
what are they telling us are we
discerning and picking up what they're
saying so when I think when my listeners
for example hear fake news what they
hear is the being in absentia words like
integrity objectivity truthfulness
verifiable Nisour thee nnessee and we
saw it exemplified here just in a few
minutes that it defaults down to an
argument ad hominem where you go after a
particular person I don't think that
serves the culture well regardless of
where you happen to sit on the political
spectrum so for me the Christian
perspective as you said is I would
rather and I you said something
brilliant you said we have to be careful
that we don't seek victory at the
expense of truth what I've observed just
from my little corner of the world is
that there are some people so hungry for
victory be it political be a policy be
whatever it is they are willing to
sacrifice anything and quite frankly
anyone to get to where they want to it's
a kind of postmodern situational ethics
that the end is so important that any
means
is justifiable to get you where you want
even if it's the abdication of truth so
that's particularly burdensome for me we
can't get out ahead of the story Dom you
brought up the idea of Brian Ross that
man lost control of objectivity
he got out ahead of the story feed the
beast you talk about the twenty-seventh
of 24/7 mandate to get the information
out there but you also mention the
sensitivity to time we have to make sure
we can verify the facts and not get out
ahead of the story because in so doing
and here's the big challenge for all of
us we lose credibility from Quinnipiac
to Harvard to NBC to Wall Street Journal
poll after poll after poll says that
there has been a marked decline in
trusting the media how much of that is
because we troubled our own house and we
inherited the wind do you find because
the word Christian has the connotation
of morality that there's a major element
of morality beyond just truth that there
is a debate within those in the
Christian media as to how the pursuit of
morality is heightened in this era of
Trump well I think and that's a very
astute question Michael I think what
we're talking about and boy this just
comes around again and again and again
particularly in Washington this is a
question of character from where I sit
so how do you handle when somebody
criticizes you do you turn around and
you return fire back again you shouldn't
do that if you're the president you
shouldn't do that if you're Jim Acosta
doing the White House briefing so it's a
question of character if a soft answer
can turn away wrath and we need to
figure out how we negotiate facts
without coming to pick a fight with
somebody so the character issue is ever
before us I think and what we're seeing
is a degradation of character add to
that culturally all of the allegations
now of sexual harassment and we are
seeing a coarseness in our culture like
we've never seen before I take that as a
personal challenge I don't know that I
would call myself a journalist I call
myself an opinion maker I am an astute
student of journalism but in order to
raise the standard to raise the bar I
think we do have to discuss these
character issues this is what happened
objective fact what would have been the
better response teaching moment for us
as stalkers very well said one of the
things I find in my own career
when the word journalism comes up or
journalist I say the best I can do is to
try to be journalistic as opposed to
being a journalist I'm journalistic okay
now we've established just how intense
the impact of Donald Trump has been on
the national discussion and the impact
of Donald Trump has been on back to what
I originally said media being
commercially minded targeting audiences
giving them what they want for the sake
of victory and the ratings not
necessarily a greater truth of what's
best for the country Joe Madison how do
you deal with the just heavy presence of
Trump in everything that is said in this
pop cultural arena of American media it
is pop cultural do you do you try to
escape from it do you do you say to
yourself more Trump and I see faces on
the panel are all gone yes you know what
else is there to talk about can you come
in to that point well first of all I'd
answer your question directly I would
imagine all of us if we're honest but
I'll speak for myself when I wake up at
3:30 or 4 o'clock in the morning the
first thing I do is turn on the
television and the first thing I asked
what the hell is he said or done no
tweet it now and and I think that's what
most of my listeners have come to to do
what has he said and and and that that
sometimes creates a problem because let
me give you an example I I walked in
today with an prepare to do an interview
with a senator Cory Booker who wanted to
talk about a bill he's introduced for
environmental and justice as well and
that's the thing and everybody's looking
at me what does that mean what does
environmental and justice me well it
means that in some very poor
rule and even urban communities there is
toxic waste
there's led and I forget the number of
cities that stretch beyond Flint I'm not
trying to bore you but the reality is we
all want clean air we all want clean
water I don't care if you're a
Republican or a Democrat and then quite
candidly nobody wanted to talk about it
because whatever happened with Flynn or
whatever happened with the lawyer who -
you know who we don't know who wrote the
tweet we don't know if it's what if
Trump wrote the tweet or the lawyer
wrote it it dominated it and and so it's
very difficult mine too to then bring
issues but really transcend our politics
I don't care if you're conservative or
liberal sitting up here but a John and I
want to talk about toxic water I bet you
in his community there is toxic waste
and then we can't get it through we
can't get it through because he has
dominated it's like a wolf that we all
go for it now you said something about
character I was always taught this - the
difference between the character and
reputation character is a combination of
qualities that you possess reputation is
what people think about you as a
difference so what we deal with mostly
is his reputation what is the man's
character and it boils down to we don't
know if he's telling the truth we don't
know if he's lying we don't know who is
telling the truth I will also say
something else you bring up morality
morality ok so who's more moral now Roy
Moore
or the women who are accusing Roy Moore
who's telling the truth are the women
tell me the truth
or his royal more telling the truth is
john conyers telling the truth or the
women who accused him telling the truth
he just retired today
I mean retired immediately so the
question of morality is of extremely and
an important one well one thing I would
close uncharged is one last point and
I'll make it 30 seconds I think what is
happening with our discussion at least I
can my sense is it's not so much our
politics I think there's a cult factor
that has developed it's it's almost like
a cult your elite your rate your leader
your religious leaders and we've seen
this with some ministers and preachers
and they can't say or do anything wrong
it's almost like a cult following and
that's what worries me more than than
anything else a number of things that
you have said worry mate and I'll play
for a moment Errol and if you'll indulge
me I'll be the eighth panelist I would
say if I were a panelist that from my
perspective observing talk radio across
the country there has been a swing in
the last five years toward stations
realizing not necessarily executing but
realizing that local talk radio is
something that can be a major factor in
preserving the role of the local radio
station that that's one thing a radio
station can do and that is serve its
local community with local issues I mean
the world does not Center on Donald
Trump in Washington even though it's
fascinating so there have been more
local hosts at local radio stations all
around the country a percentage-wise
we track this over the last five years
but unfortunately based on a point that
Joe brought up they're all obsessed with
talking about Donald Trump as a result
the role of the media in local
communities where the real action is
I mean local small cities are hotbeds of
corruption and local corrupt politicians
and business leaders are getting away
with murder because the watchdogs every
town had its watchdog the watchdog is
playing to the crowd they want to hear
about Trump and I'm not saying as much
in your case because you're a local host
but you're dealing with a major region
but the rest of you are for the most
part quite national in scope but local
hosts have to say what's my
responsibility here am I gonna throw my
my little opinion when I ask them they
go well I present the local perspective
on it but that to me is a bit of a
cop-out although I understand again it's
a business and it does play to numbers
now John you have had you're going to
resign I mean but bear with me I
basically have the situation strategized
as I'm going along and your face and
reactions as I'm reading everybody are
just bursting with all kinds of
potential so I'm going to ask you a
question you can add to it what you want
but I'm not I don't want you to answer
it I want to talk to Scott Bertram he's
the only one who has not spoken yet but
I'm gonna ask you the question now this
is a tease and you'll answer it after we
follow up with Scott the question is
going to be and this is I think you
deserve a little time for this because I
really want you to do some
soul-searching what would you do if you
woke up one day and you found out that
something happened that proved beyond
doubt that you have been wrong in your
support of Donald Trump and that he was
just a terrible guy who has done
terrible things how would you handle it
don't answer now Scott let's go to you
we're gonna get back to you Scott
and the right after these words from
Scott Bertram
Scot you deal with young broadcasters
what do you tell them what do you tell
them is they they're facing
going into the media in 2017 how do you
deal with all of these issues in terms
of molding young minds that are just
entering this business something I
wanted to get to valid mention this and
it feeds into your question which is you
know served of host liberal hosts
there's no there's no script there's no
talking points earlier this summer all
the Salem hosts were here at Kirby
Center to do their shows he was here
that as Prager was here my Gallagher was
here Michael Medved was here Sean
Hannity was actually here for a
different day when I was here helping
all of them and there is this there is a
fought out there that all these hosts
are the same and all these hosts have
the same talking points and they think
they have a script every single one of
those hosts ran their show differently
every single one of those show hosts
produced the show differently they they
took their cues from different places
they work with their producers
differently if they were different from
top to bottom and so I came back and was
talking to my students about how
everyone's different everyone prepares
different ways everyone argues different
ways and people are going to be louder
some people are gonna be screamers and
people are gonna be more cerebral you
might say and so what you know when I
when I work with them on the shows they
do and now all the shows that we have on
the station are political in nature we
have some that are non political
explicitly but you know 30 40 % of the
shows try to focus on politics
michigan-based or national based and I
really just tell them you know think for
yourself I can hear I can hear you know
when students are doing shows and and
they're they're parroting talking point
so they're they're repeating something
they've heard elsewhere what I want them
to do is to read research and make their
own arguments construct your own
arguments what are your strongest points
and I also tell them what are your what
are your opponent's strongest points and
how do you refute them why are they
wrong why are their best arguments wrong
and so I I want them to to think for
themselves and and
the show that is able to both make their
arguments well and sort of anticipate
the arguments that opponents might make
as well how do they respond do you find
yourself sometimes having difficulty
teaching this against the pressure of
the outside world
sort of like little league baseball
players scratching themselves in a
spitting no scratching or spitting is
allowed in the studio first I know
they're they're open and you know
they're at an age you know eighteen to
twenty-two or so where a lot of them
grew up on terrestrial radio and a lot
of them still listen to rest rail radio
whether it be rush or hue or whomever
but that you know these podcasts now are
becoming very large and you where we are
in Hillsdale penetration from stations
and all that great so they're listening
online or listening to podcast and so
they're getting a lot of different
viewpoints and they're hearing a lot of
different ways to do shows I think what
I do talk to them about about trying to
structure their show in a way that makes
sense
where's your beginning where's your
middle where's your end how do you
convince listeners to stick with you
through your points and through your
arguments I think they're receptive to
it I I kind of leave our hosts alone for
the first three four shows let them
figure things out then we sit down and
talk about you know what can you do
better how do you structure this better
how do you make the show more
interesting more informative more
entertaining thank you Scott okay John
you're on I hope the audience sticks
with you despite my lead-in do great
leader well if I were to get up one day
and there was evidence of what you said
I would be shocked because I know the
man and so it would defy all the history
that I have but look you can't run
raised five great children build a ten
billion dollar company and then sit
there and say the man is of low
character those don't wash as far as
Janet said earlier about about his
character what people mistake for
character or morality is you just don't
like the guy style I get it you don't
like his style you don't like his tone
you don't like his tweets you don't like
how he grazes his hands and how he goes
if he's attacked he fires back you just
don't like the guy I get it but that
it's nothing to do with his policies or
how he's become successful
you got remember Trump came into this
campaign when we joined this campaign
Trump was at 1% he was a joke nobody
took him seriously now I come from the
perspective Joe mentioned the word cult
okay I'm not sure what that means in
this instance I'm a true believer in the
policies of this president and he took
on Republican orthodoxy head-on Pro gay
rights right you got to go back and
remember
control the borders pro-immigration he
attacked these stupid trade deals we
have open borders after TPP US workers
getting screwed jobs going overseas
wages down he became popular because of
the policies that he was espousing he
also said he would protect the United
States social contract net not cut
Medicaid not cut Medicare got Paul Ryan
the other day
well after we passed the tax cut I'm
going to reformat welfare what the hell
does that mean that the object of the
Trump presidency is to make the country
prosperous and rich one of the other
policies get out of these wars so that
we can then pay for food stamps chip
Medicaid Medicare Social Security so he
has a clear agenda that everybody seems
to get garbled because they don't like
his style and as far as room poor is
concerned and fake news sure you didn't
answer women's gender you didn't answer
my question I would be shocked you
didn't know
I asked you the question based on the
fact that you'd be shocked so and then
let me give me a 30-second answer
alright well give me give me a 10-second
answer than a 30-second answer first
question is it possible that you could
be shocked and would be wrong
sure and I'm gonna ask bill press the
same question so okay so you do realize
days did you realize you're infallible
do you know you're not because I worry
about that all the time I always say to
myself like god I may not be right I we
live in a world where we have to have an
opinion pretty quickly and I'm not so
sure I'm always right
a matter of fact a lot of times I have
read old articles I've written I look at
old videos I've done one of the problems
with being in the digital age is
everything's recorded I wince I say oh
my gosh you know I like to talk about
all my predictions that come true I
don't like to know that anybody can go
on google and see me say some pretty
stupid stuff can I enter but just a
second I do one because John and I do
this every four how it's getting hot
what do you know but let me let me
answer your question about cult and
here's what I mean by a call anytime a
man goes on radio and says I can shoot
somebody in the middle of Fifth Avenue
oh that was a medic excuse me I didn't
interrupt you
as soon as when a metaphor or not and
everybody doesn't always catch a
metaphor when somebody says I can go in
the middle of Fifth Avenue and shoot
somebody in this day and age and not
lose any supporter
that's a cult mentality good point and
and and let me make one other point you
said he got popular through his public
policy you're right
I'll give John that argument you're
absolutely right listen get rid of
Social Security let's change Medicare
and a whole bunch of other public policy
issues I'm not gonna take that argument
from you but let me tell you what my
audience thinks his popularity came from
when he sat there and accused don't
Barack Obama of being born in Kenya and
then said he was gonna send detectives
to Hawaii and and said that the birth
certificate was fake came back didn't
find anything
but wait a minute then turned around
last week and said it again bet he
wasn't born in the United States that's
how he became and my audience's mind
that's what really shot him up beyond
the true conservatives that we have okay
his moderator we've had two interesting
points and I applaud both of you for
addressing it well they'll press what if
you woke up tomorrow and the stock
market's booming and Main Street is
booming I do want to point out
mainstream doesn't necessarily boom
anymore when the stock market does and
that's troubling that being said Bill do
you ever wonder like if suddenly we
never go to war we everything is
de-escalated the kim-jong on the thing
never never comes to some type of
negative ruin prosperity booms America
is great again what would you do I would
hope I would give me I would think and I
would hope I would give him credit for
the good things that he has done I'm a
Democrat I'm a liberal I make no bones
about it I'm a talk show host I'm a
progressive if you want to use that word
which I hate I'm a liberal talk show
host okay
I supported george w bush and his
immigration a comprehensive immigration
reform because i thought he had the
right right approach
Barack Obama tried the same thing didn't
work I wrote a book at the end of the
Obama presidency called buyer's remorse
how rock obama disappointed progressives
so I'm think I've proven that I'm
capable of criticizing my guys or
applauding people on the other team
wonderful in there when they're wrong
but I have to say John just for the
record when I can blow another point if
I can when I have the mic for the record
yeah I don't like Donald trum style I
think the American people deserve better
in terms of just the way he handles
himself as a president but that's not my
problem with Donald Trump I don't like
the fact that he tried to gut the first
national health insurance plan that
we've ever had I don't like the fact
that he's trying to get rid of the
dreamers I don't like the fact that he
pulled out of the
Paris Accords I don't like his tax cut a
permanent tax cut for big business and a
temporary cut for individuals so it's
the policies that I disagree with and I
think that's what this is all about
democrat or republican we focus on their
policies so you're saying bill let you
get you a second point but you're saying
that there there is a policy discussion
in all of this hoopla that that does
provide a series of choices to Americans
I talked about his hair or as jowls or
whatever legs under the eyes I talked
about his policy okay real quick another
point off quickly the other point I just
have to say this because they thought
this panel was are going to be about
media in the age of journalism I just
want to say as heretical as it may sound
I think Donald Trump has been great for
journalism it's challenging it's tougher
but at the same time we've never had so
much to talk about
I remember the dog days of summer when
you'd be thinking about oh my god how am
I going to fill three hours or two hours
and Donald Trump gives us material up
the Gazoo every single day secondly I
think he has triggered the best
investigative journalism we've seen in
this country since the days of Watergate
now I see I see that we have two people
reacting the first one was Dom I'm not
going to forget about you Hugh Dom your
reaction hey beau I Meyer you greatly
have done stuff with you but deep down
you don't sense that would trump it's
the vehemence is driven by more than the
policies the policies he hasn't exactly
followed through on I think as a
conservative and he doesn't articulate
them well and he's all over the place
with them I think there's an irrational
thing here and it goes back to again
this guy shouldn't have been president
how did this happen and I think when you
look at mrs. Clinton as a candidate when
you look at Mitch McConnell you can see
I know what my listeners that every bit
as much Trump is an antidote to coming
here to Washington to break up Mitch
McConnell and the boys every bit as much
as the policies I will give credit
though of something I like he did make
trade and these things that eat away at
me at NAFTA he did make them things that
we talked about and that these people in
rural America are articulating the
opiate crisis now even though he doesn't
are
particulate it correctly through the
force of his personality he did get it
something that's really important and
wasn't sexy before yeah quickly everyone
taken from you I agree with him on NAFTA
and TPP and and I said so okay let's go
to Hue and then Janet I'm gonna come to
you Michael I got a question from online
is this streaming or I just I responded
a Niall Ferguson not special that you're
taping it and to look at talkers
magazine calmly yes we will we will
processing everything that we find
objectionable that doesn't agree with my
point of view I wanted to make two
points one about the age of Trump I
cheat pi was my gifts on MSNBC on
Saturday the biggest threat to am radio
is not Donald Trump or never Trump hers
it is the fact that ground
signal distortion is ruining the signal
of every AM station in America and
anyone who loves talk radio needs to
talk to the FCC about allowing us to
power up within our guidelines because
it's destroy it's it's handheld devices
it's a it's a great deal electronic
disturbance so that bill and I used to
work we've known each other for twenty
eight years we did news we've been
friends for 20 years he'd been wrong for
28 years but we would work on am 640 a
Clear Channel in Los Angeles in 1989 we
began and we could get calls from
Mississippi those Clear Channel things
are dinosaurs and they're killing the
signal and I guarantee you this morning
in Los Angeles with Ventura County on
fire people are listening to AM 1074 the
local news about which highways were
closed and where they could evacuate and
which schools were open and we got to
save AM radio and Michael what you do
for that thank you I appreciate that
because AM radio needs saving here's
what Donald Trump is done that is better
than anything else we can talk about he
taught every political figure to go
anywhere and talk to anyone at any time
about anything that's why he won the
nomination he flooded the zone on CNN
NBC MSNBC he did all but one debate
his only argument throughout the
primaries with with Fox News he would go
anywhere to talk with anyone so I'm very
proud of the fact that two weeks ago
Secretary Clinton came on my show and I
had negotiated for weeks to get her on
and we agreed to 30 minutes and I had
to the book there's a lot in the book at
the end of 32 minutes she said to me I'm
having fun here let's keep going and she
admitted that she ought to have done
conservative media I believe that if she
had done conservative media she would
have won the presidency and so I think
what President Trump has shown that it
is good to get out of your bubble and to
talk to anyone about anything at any
time in all media ought to be thankful
for them especially since she's a
conservative Janet have two questions
for you
question one John mentioned get past the
style and get into the substance of the
policies how important is it for people
that are in positions of power such as
the President of the United States or
the chairman of the Federal Reserve who
can screw the whole stock market up by a
misstatement the way the words have a
lot of meaning how important is it for
the President of the United States not
to be loose with his lips well I think
it goes to the idea of deportment we
expect a certain style a characteristic
to subscribe to our leaders for many
reasons not the least of which is I
think we tend to look at these people
and I'm going to use an arcane idea here
as role models we used to look at sports
figures as role models and political
leaders as role models and well the
bigger they are the harder they fall as
the saying goes but I've heard a couple
of interesting things that really go to
your question which is this idea that in
the fog of war it's really about policy
I'd like to believe that but objective
numbers tell me otherwise Harvard
University of all places took a look at
the press coverage of George W Bush and
Bill Clinton in their first 100 days and
the negative to positive for both
Clinton and Bush was 60 to 40 for Trump
it has been 80 to 20 so there is a
particular vitriol in the press I'm
going to go to the title of this panel
its media and journalism in the age of
Trump we default to Trump I want to go
back to journalism and media here and I
think that while you have issues with
the president the question on the table
for us as people who are in the media is
how do we react and how do we handle all
of this so Joe you said something very
important and a tie
is something that bill said earlier
which is if in fact policy is the issue
and I would hope so because policy
should in theory outlast any politician
right politicians come and go if they
don't retire themselves they're
unelected or by constitutional restraint
they can't go beyond eight years so I
learned something when I came to
Washington a long time ago and that is
you have a choice of perspective you can
look at somebody as an eighty-percent
friend and a 20% enemy or you can look
at them as a 20% friend and an 80% enemy
so joe talked about the idea of clean
water that's something where if you push
personality aside and you really go to
policy you have the opportunity to have
substantive and important discussions
you talked about Hillary coming on its
program that's an indictment for some of
us and that is what are we doing to open
the welcome mat and the door of
opportunity I am an all-comers policy
person I welcome anybody in the
marketplace of ideas I'm in fact I'll
quote Tevye from fiddler on the roof'
you I like your ideas that wouldn't give
you a kopeck for but you I like
I might not necessarily like the person
I have on the show because of their
worldview but I want to hear their
worldview Abraham Lincoln said when you
prepare your case and this goes to
something Scott said you spend 20% of
your time preparing your argument and
80% of your time preparing your
opponent's argument I want to know what
other people believe and where they're
coming from quite frankly it makes me a
better apologist for what I believe and
why I believe it so I'm wondering if we
shouldn't get out of our boxes a little
bit be more willing to go boldly into
the marketplace talk to people we
wouldn't normally hang out with see
where they're coming from examine their
ideas I happen to believe that my ideas
are built on solidity but I don't think
that my ideas are going to crumble if I
talk to somebody else
who holds an antithetical worldview in
fact they might challenge me to either
change my thinking or to become even
more committed to my perspective and
I'll and I'll get to your answer your
comment in a second and often there
isn't one right and one wrong sometimes
politics and disagreement is based on
who shoes you're standing in it's just a
civilized way of battling out
differences for the piece of the pie
that we call the Commonwealth
and and we lose sight of that and that's
why sometimes compromise is a not an
honorable thing Joe you had a comment I
just wanted I found it interesting this
8020 since I've been in Washington all
these years what I've learned is that
there and it's it's a book that William
clay senior congressman the former
congressman is from st. Louis Road you
know he said that in politics there are
no permanent friends or permanent
enemies only permanent interest and and
and therein lies what I think we're
gotten away from is is is whose interest
is it is being dealt with when it comes
to public policy there's something else
my perspective is entirely different and
everybody on this panel why a beak
because my experience is different there
are certain commonalities we may have it
might be education it it might be the
fact let me tell you the question I
asked on my show I think the slogan make
America great again bothers me and I'll
tell you why all my life I've been told
America is the greatest country on the
planet when did it stop so why do we
have to say again now when I asked
African Americans when wasn't what do
they mean make it great again since when
most of my audience will say oh you talk
to conservatives not conservatives I
shouldn't say you talk to some and
they'll go oh it was 1964 1965 that
perspective that's my perspective and
what happens is we don't share or listen
to other people's perspective I I mean I
got to I got to be very honest with you
you talk about work outside he should
get outside his bubble tell him to come
on the job
doesn't show don't go in some talk with
black talk radio you're talking about
and I will tell Bernie Bernie Sanders
don't think don't you think he didn't
get a pass Bernie Sanders came on my
show I mean it was like pulling teeth
bill to get him to come on the show and
then one of the questions that killed
him I said look if you become president
United States will you apologize for
slavery you know he couldn't answer it
didn't answer it wouldn't answer it and
it cost him big-time vote so it's I'm
sorry I
he started let me you know what he
started doing
he started lecturing me on the history
of slavery excuse my French but I yeah I
know but but but he learned from that
experience because he ended up on in a
panel discussion in Harlem and obviously
one of my listeners heard the exchange
and asked him the same question directly
and he said oh yeah I apologize as soon
as I get elected but that that's that's
again so I would say in the 8th to go
back to your point about the age of
Trump Donald Trump and his folk ought to
come on a show where there are different
perspectives and not in and sell Europe
your your position you may not be
successful at it but if if Hillary would
have won is she gone on conservative
talk radio you know maybe some of the
Conservatives would convince more
African Americans to vote form if they
come on our show we are so into our
boxes and we're not dealing with issues
and that's the what bothers me about the
age of Trump and it didn't just start
with Trump we are in our boxes and we're
not dealing with common
ality and I'll go back and in where I
started when you know you you look at
Lavar ball we try to talk about him
today the father who's run around you
know it's talking about oh I'm gonna
pull my son from UCLA now what's the
commonality we all have who in the hell
would pull their sons from a full-time
basketball scholarship because your kid
was too stupid not to steal something in
China that's what we that's what's not
happening
and we can't get to that because style
and it is about style ministers have
styles that's why you go to a certain
church you like a style style is real
John you're damn right okay Dom Giordano
we're gonna this is fascinating and
thank you Joe and I found what you said
to be very very moving and I personally
agree that perspective is everything and
and it leads to respect a respect really
is is vital for a democracy to continue
to exist respect so let's talk about a
bigger issue that all media and all
journalism is subject to and that is the
health of the First Amendment
DOM do you think that the First
Amendment is stronger less strong state
of the First Amendment which I'm always
concerned about as a result of the
turbulence that journalism is going
through Hugh you had mentioned that this
is a great day for media and and I think
Hugh said that this has stimulated
investigative journalism more bill bill
said it again I was wearing my glasses I
just see a white blur at the end of the
tape and you probably see a white blur
at this end of it I said I wouldn't I
should have put you back there
I would have given that are countless to
the two so my my vision problems here
state of the First Amendment
oh boy after that okay well I think the
pockets of the First Amendment college
campuses where I still teach a class are
under fire with a I hate to use the term
snowflakes but that's what a lot of
these kids are and they're being egged
on and plugged for a Hillsdale who does
not do that but the the First Amendment
is not under fire Trump is not Mussolini
we're not dragging journalists out into
the street Jake Tapper comes on with me
once a week he's a Philly guy today said
boy you know I don't even know what to
start with we have eight or nine
different things mainly thanks to Trump
to talk about today
there's no squelching of that he said
when he started his show they were
figuring out how are they going to fill
an hour up so I don't see any of that
sort of stuff it's way overdone the
First Amendment thing that I'm looking
at today is the cake shop case and the
cake shop case Janet is just that is
that's right up here I thought was a
religious freedom thing as a talk show
host I sent it in on that a year or two
ago whatever it was I see it more
dramatically now because I had the
experience and I brought him back on of
a guy who is kind of a Nazi figure not
the bad kind of Nazis he's just a mixed
up guy who named his kid Adolf Hitler
did you say not the bad kind of yes
[Laughter]
which is wait wait wait so he he wait a
minute he is not a good Nazi he's a
mixed up guy though he's not going to be
goose-stepping in here oh he's named
Adolf Hitler takes the kid to a shop
right along with his wife to get a cake
inscribed
happy birthday Adolf Hitler the legal
name of his son they say as I would get
the hell out of here and they don't
serve Him now did the people I had on
that have national perspective none of
them have heard of that case the reason
you haven't heard of it is that's an
unpopular guy and popular opinion and
people are solidly with chop right this
poor Baker in Colorado
it's getting these grandiose edicts
about your a public service you have to
do with the customer once like out
you're going to come in and tell me I'm
gonna put a confederate flag on a
birthday cake or I'm going to put
something anti-italian yeah I loved
echoes or something not going to do that
and I think a business owner certainly
has a right to do that that's the first
amendment that's under fire that you
have people that are so politically
correct so driven so misinformed that
they see this cake shop Baker as a
threat to something in our society that
is non-existent and I'll bring it back
to Trump Trump then instinctual way or
whoever gets in his ear has a way of
getting involved in one cultural
hot-button after another be it levar
ball who's an ingrate and that was the
issue there be at the NFL players with
the knee or any number of array of feuds
and I know that my listeners whether
it's right wrong or indifferent are
entertained by this part of it is
entertainment and they don't see Trump
as a threat to the First Amendment or
anything else but a guy that's taking on
these people that have been mocking them
laughing at them showing disdained and
along the way they're entertained by it
is there any media today I'll let
anybody jump in on this first hand up is
there any major media today that isn't
primarily entertainment well when I
first started in talk radio a program
director and this was those who remember
this you had the Fairness Doctrine so
you know and that's out the window and
last year we brought up the Fairness
Doctrine and Hugh jumped me so I'm not
gonna bring it up this time but but but
lots of it there's some people now who
are talking seriously about bringing
back to Fairness Doctrine I mean there's
some if I may inject that goes back to
what you said about saving AM radio
which I wanted to say and then we'll get
right back to your but but the damn
radio doesn't need being saved because
all radio is going the way of the
Internet and I personally think I don't
speak officially this is personally that
more people listen to AM radio now
online don't even know they are then
listening to it on an AM radio set yeah
but I but the program director came back
from a conference with some consultants
and said we're going to start something
now called infotainment infotainment and
started to lecture us about infotainment
never heard the term what is
infotainment and matter of fact is you
may know anything remember Michael
Packer used to be program and so he said
it's infotainment that now all
information has to be presented in an
entertaining kind of way and I'm not
talking about variety show type in
fátima but I'm talking about what you
were making reference to as you know
that people think it's entertainment
that this is a joke but once again that
goes back to perspective your listeners
may think it's entertaining for a group
of black athletes at the NFL to take a
knee well let me tell you something my
my folks don't think it's entertaining
because they're the ones that when they
take that freakin uniform off and their
number is not on that uniform they're
the ones that get jacked up by the
police so what is entertaining to one
group of people may be real serious to
another well I just add though that
there's nothing wrong Joe and you're one
of the most entertaining guys and I know
you for ever in a natural style to be
entertaining and informative Trump
doesn't always accomplish that it gets
mangled but that's what I strive for and
you certainly don't have to strive for
it I don't think it's a natural you're
being if I get speak for you for a
moment you are being you and that is
naturally informative intelligent
elevated but there's a hell of a lot of
entertainment in there I'm gonna get to
you right afterwards okay but bill but
first off let bill jump in now building
I just want to jump in a couple of
points because we're all bouncing around
first of all I just got to say Joseph it
spoke about my experience my experience
just just to speak to that one second I
grew up in a small town in northern
Delaware in a segregated town went to a
white school
to a white church and you know the other
school the Negro school we didn't call
it that was outside of town a mile
outside of town my father had a small
business
he had a gas station the recast stations
over three gas stations in town the
other two gas stations wouldn't serve
black people my father did my father
served Irish he said Italian he served
polish he sorted anybody who came there
and for him to turn them away for any
reason I think is the same as that Baker
turning that gay couple away in Denver
this is not this is not First Amendment
this is a 14th amendment this is equal
rights I believe if you're in public
service you're a business to serve the
public you serve the public and you
don't hide behind religion what I would
call a phony a use of religion to to try
to hide your basic biases or racism or
homophobia are you aware though that
that's a you know vague concept that you
must decide who you want to do business
but I don't think it's a fake concept at
all I saw a sign walking over here that
said love your neighbors and at the
bottom it said without exception
I'll live by that rule I don't think
vague at all you mean you don't you
don't have a bias against certain
individuals you don't wanna do business
with them just because you don't like
them I'm just saying if you heard and if
you're in business view of a public if
you have a bake shop or if you have a a
gas station or if you've got a laundry
whatever then you are there to serve the
public bill what I think here that the
guy is not the mistreating or not
serving people that are gay that he
knows that are gay isn't it the test
you're asking him to express something
that what about Halloween he doesn't
want to be involved in Halloween you're
gonna make him have to do Halloween he
knew they were a gay okay we got we got
the point of this debate let's go to you
and then I want Janet's input on this
because it's it's really a fascinating
exercise in in freedom and it's that
area what gets nebula just in one quick
point on and okay quick point okay I
came back to Washington to do crossfire
with Bob Novak and Pat Buchanan damn
right it was entertaining and you know
what if we do I hope it was informative
I know it was informative I hope it was
also entertaining I think we have to be
did you ever juice it up to make it
entertaining hell yes yeah I'd go after
Novak no but I mean did you ever like
say to each other hey will you do this
all no no we didn't do that because of
it Novak played all the time to the
camera all I'm saying is let's not be
too stodgy here right you want people to
listen and you want people to have fun
listening and to learn something and so
there's nothing wrong with a little bit
of entertainment in every show you grab
at you before somebody jumps and
everybody is concerned with ratings even
NPR and PBS it doesn't
nothing happens till somebody sells
something so we all have to be
entertaining and not dull or there will
be no media and no one will watch
anything First Amendment response I
teach First Amendment I teach it at
Fowler school I for 21 years it's in
fine shape what Bill doesn't really
believe in his coerced speech if I had
an hour with Bill I could walk him
around to why Jack Phillips ought to be
left alone in masterpiece cake shop he
serves same-sex couples he does not wish
to use his art to propagate a message
with which he does not agree
fundamentally and we would hold that to
be true for example for a devout Muslim
who did not wish to make representations
of Allah which is forbidden by their
faith and therefore the First Amendment
has always had protections against
coerced speech they apply to Jack
Phillips I have no doubt he will win
this case the question is and I'll give
it to Janet where do you draw the line
and I'm glad you brought up the issue of
coerce speech because it goes back to
what you said which is you said your
politics were the first amendment that
really is the linchpin in this entire
conversation and so as we're sitting or
having this conversation what they're
really arguing at the Court is whether
or not you can have something known as
coerced speech I don't care where you
sit on the political spectrum if we move
to the day and age where the government
said rightly or left ly this is what you
have to say every single one of us would
stand up and object and so that's what's
really in the dock at the Supreme Court
right now is whether or not a
governmental entity can coerce you to
say something that you don't like Nat
Hentoff at the Village Voice said it
beautifully
he said free speech for thee but not for
me so what's going on in our culture
that you can't have somebody come to an
Ivy League school unless somebody throws
a brick through a window or starts a
building on fire B
you disagree with what you think is
going to be the content of that
individual speech how do you defeat a
bad idea with a better one
you don't silence speech who disagree
with you encourage more participators in
the marketplace of ideas what I've seen
and I find this an interesting
juxtaposition I was at a Big Ten
University in the 1960s where they came
in and disturbed our classroom put black
paint on their face chanted anti-war
slogans and didn't let me get my lecture
to get my grade for that semester
because they were protesting the war
okay all I heard during the 1960's was
protect free speech for Tex P speech I
don't have to agree with the speech I
hear but as the old adage says I have to
agree 100% that you have the right to
say it and as talkers that has to be a
definer for who we are well here should
we deal with all the time I'm the one
who gave Al Franken presented him with
the freedom of speech award and then
threw him off the stage halfway through
his speech that actually happened and
I'll spare you all the story but it's my
best one
Scott how do you deal with your the
question sure are you going to take it
back the award no I just wanted to get
off the stage no no no no I'm not
talking about I'm talking about with his
because that's an issue no I don't say
he got the award based on that time you
know you give the award you live with
the shame that he was at so having women
so should they so should these
journalism societies take back Charlie
Rose I don't think so my personal
opinion is that you give an award you
live with it they got you gave them the
award you're responsible for the way it
was at that time and you live with the
the shame of it or just the fact that it
happened or just the fact that one of
the great one of the great things we
have in a bad syndrome of today's life
is that there's a terrible plague of
short-term attention span people forget
anyway just let it go how do you handle
the First Amendment now that you're
working under a system where the
Constitution is academically one of its
pillars Hillsdale College is known for
its constitutional studies and I'll push
in a little direction
do you find that there's a lot of
misunderstanding about what the First
Amendment means um some but but but not
a lot everybody gets a big packet before
they do anything on the station right so
what what what can you do what can't you
do why can why can't you do it we're a
non-commercial station by definition so
I'm talking in a broader sense just just
an understanding not among students but
of the human race about what freedom of
speech per the First Amendment to the
Constitution means because even in this
discussion today the constant back to
Janet and that discussion some people
don't know the difference between
freedom to express religion or freedom
from somebody forcing their religion on
you that the thee and me is terribly a
blurry area in the minds of many to me
it's clear to me it's just the United
States government or the government does
not have the right to censor you on
expression unless a couple of exceptions
but I didn't you know John could not
have called me up and said you're
infringing on my First Amendment right
by not inviting me to be on this panel I
would say it's my panel start your own
this panel is a an extension of my First
Amendment right to present what I
consider to be a well-rounded group and
and if somebody calls Hugh on the phone
and says I want to say so-and-so and
Hugh says no you're a jerk I don't want
you on you sound too old and I want
young listeners I'm not talking about
that subject I know it's important but
I'm not talking about it invariably
they're gonna say you're infringing on
my First Amendment right well no that
show is your First Amendment right more
so it's Salem's First Amendment right
people don't understand this we are
constantly we actually had a
conversation in class last week because
I was a producer in a former life I was
a call screener and you get people who
call and demand to be on there because
it's my right to be on the show you have
to tell them that that's in fact not the
case I write to tell you you can't be on
the show it's our show get your own show
right and so we do we discuss things
like that you know in class and at the
station
I think partially because of what
Hillsdale teaches I have not had real
problems with what the First Amendment
is what it means I think the students
have a really good understanding of what
the First Amendment means and what it
means to them as broadcasters and yeah
good can I give you a true story you'll
love this
I knew him before he knew me w WB b FM
i'm doing this show midnight
5:30 midnight only black guy on the
whole freaking show I'm pulled Channel
it's worthy or whatever the station I'm
pulled in I'm pulled in by Chuck
Schwartz and Diane Aryan and said you
cannot talk about black issues while
you're on the air now well now the
question is for this panel would you
have fired me or would and if I'd have
said excuse me no and he did they did I
mean that's what they did that's exactly
and in Philadelphia after the
neighborhood burned down move the moon
folk now so I meant to what I did first
amendment next morning I interviewed
Louis Farrakhan
the first hour the second hour
I interviewed Ron Brown who was running
for chairman of the Democratic National
Committee to show the difference between
the next morning Jerry was with me
I was called in and fired now whose
first amendment is being violated so it
goes back to what you said Charles sorts
owned the station yeah he had the right
to be stupid
so what not well does a second civil so
so the question then is if I went to the
Supreme Court whose case would prevail
Charles horse who's the owner or Joe
Madison who was fired because he
exercised First Amendment I don't I mean
I'm not a man but it's but it's a clear
it's a clear-cut answer Hugh well yeah
absolutely yeah
I do for now yeah alright but I want it
I want it I do good I want to bring this
I want to bring this to a conclusion and
I'd like but what I'm saying Michael is
is and I'm very serious about this so
where's the seat is does this cloud the
First Amendment because what you're
saying it's Schwartz because he owns it
well it's it's he is the one who in the
capitalistic system and an entrepreneur
system he is the one who has ownership
of that property he owns he owns the
platform so ownership and capitalism
supersedes First Amendment
constitutional right it's not a
constitutional right for you to have a
platform it's a constitutional right for
you to have an opinion without the
government interfering it doesn't
guarantee you a soapbox you could as a
remedy claim that he's not serving the
public and oppose his reassignment of
the license that's a way but no you do
not have the right to claim First
Amendment that a newspaper doesn't run
your letter or that your employer
doesn't I was first told I'm answering
you why I'm not taking but what I'm
saying to you is the truth but I was
told you can't talk about black folk
that's just like I was once told I can't
play Peter Paul and Mary no no no no no
Peter Paul and Miriam no no it's
artistic expression no back when I back
when I was when I was no no no you hold
let me make let you I'll let you have
the second to artistic expression is
equal to political opinion under the
First Amendment
there have been they put elephant dung
on the wall in the Brooklyn Museum and
there was a and taxpayer money was
involved in that I don't remember the
details of the case but it comes to mind
and there was a First Amendment argument
about it what is art
and and and who has the right to decide
what is artistic expression here you're
a scholar on this subject am I on the
right
[Music]
to fire you there is no First Amendment
violation if the government told your
owner to fire you you would have a civil
rights cause and you would have the
First Amendment but if the government's
not involved there is no constitutional
issue period and and and it's not I'm
saying that's right I I said he was
stupid because it was bad business it
was bad policy it wasn't smart but this
goes on all the time and the reason I
made the remark about the music is in my
early days when I was in music radio and
I was in a kind of radio where the DJ's
were the curators we picked the music
and the format was called free form and
if you don't think there were battles I
I was prepared for my thirty years 35
year career and talk radio by the
battles I went through through my 15
year career in music radio I was a
pioneer in that arena and the battles
were fierce because the music related to
lifestyle it related to whether you were
hip or unhip whether you were cooler and
cool it even related to politics that's
where I cut my teeth on that an artistic
expression Lenny Bruce look at look at
the history Howard Stern it's not just
you know serious issues it could be
dirty words it's fascinating and and yes
exactly
nor was the government involved in
whether colin kaepernick could take a
knee it was the player association union
contract that was at play in that and
that's why a lot of people felt that
Trump had no right to be in that
discussion and then some people feel
trump has a right to be in every
discussion because of the culture I'm
going to but we're gonna I'm gonna spare
everybody the obligation of doing the
final statement cuz that'll take a half
hour but I want John Frederick to make
the final statement and I get
Frederick's I want you to give us an
honest answer and don't be too long but
just come up with something cool
who is more entertained always cool who
Joe is very everybody hears Nosal and
everybody in this audience is cool I
mean looking at all your faces and you
seem interested if not I would have just
called it off a half hour ago but you're
not that interested where we're gonna go
another half hour
well we'll be at it well be we'll be
done in three minutes based on whether
John is able to really be succinct I
want you to be the kicker who's more
entertaining you were Donald Trump and
who cares about being entertaining more
in terms of when he gets up in the
morning and he sets his tone for the day
oh if you listen to my show I'm much
more entertaining than the president
there's no question about that but look
he has changed things there's no
question about it pre Trump those that
do like Joe and I and Bill that go on in
the morning in fact bill and I were at
the the Philadelphia Convention I
believe by each other in a Crampton spot
we would prepare in the in the evening
and then go to bed and get up at 3:30
whatever we do I don't do that now there
is no point in
aperi anything until you get up at 3:00
a.m. because the first thing you do is
you turn on your Twitter and see what
the hell he's tweeted out today and that
dominates everything so he has there's
no question that the this administration
and this president has changed that I do
want to make one comment though about
Bernie Sanders bill he came on my show
three times and he allowed me to spend
the day with him in Iowa that's probably
why he got beat so I just want fun to
throw that out probably shouldn't have
done that but the as far as the First
Amendment is concerned I think this
president has done more to encourage
people's First Amendment rights than
anything I've ever seen the day he got
inaugurated on a Friday the next day on
a Saturday there was a million women's
March and he hadn't said anything or
done anything so they were all
expressing their First Amendment rights
and so I think that this president
although he tangles with the press and
he gets into it with April with April
Ryan and John and it costs and other
people I think he has encouraged
everybody to get involved and the media
to take proactive stance and some ators
and I happen to think that is a great
thing nice kicker okay Hugh Hewitt bill
Prescott Bertram John Frederick's Janet
Parshall Joe Madison and Dom Giordano
thank you
[Applause]